Okay, so we've got our form,
you've done all this before.
We've got our error case.
We've got a shell of a success case.
We are going to go ahead and fix that now soon,
and we're rendering our form nicely with our error message
and preserving our fields.
So far nothing is new to you other than the templates.
The next thing we're going to do is we're going to
start adding the database so we can store the art work
that is submitted by users.
The way you define an entity
in Google app engine is to define a class.
So we're going to make a class called art,
and this is going to represent a submission from the user,
and this inherits from db.model,
and db.model is something that is included from Google.
You can see I've actually already imported up here
from Google.appengine.ext import db,
and so our art class inherits from the db.model class,
and this, this will allow us to create an entity.
So the first thing we need to do is
we need to define the types of this entity.